hello everyone
welcome to this live session on
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning by simply learn
in this session we will cover all the
important supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms that are widely used
with hands-on demonstrations in python
our instructors with rich experience in
machine learning will take us through
this course but before we begin make
sure to subscribe to the simply learn
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
so we will start by understanding the
basics of machine learning from a short
animated video followed by the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised learning
we will then jump into learning the
various algorithms from scratch
so we will understand linear regression
logistic regression decision tree and
random forest we'll then look at support
vector machines and k-nearest neighbor
algorithm with a hands-on demonstration
in python
finally we'll get an idea about
unsupervised learning algorithms such as
k-means clustering and principal
component analysis
we will conclude this session with
regularization machine learning so let's
get started
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do and much faster
well that's called machine learning but
it's a lot more than just learning it's
also about understanding and reasoning
so today we will learn about the basics
of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity
and the gender of voice for simplicity
let's just use tempo and intensity for
now so here tempo is on the x-axis
ranging from relaxed to fast whereas
intensity is on the y-axis ranging from
light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song p so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether ball likes it or not
not able to guess whether this ball will
like it or dislike it are the choices
unclear correct we could easily classify
song a but when the choice became
complicated as in the case of song b yes
and that's where machine learning comes
in let's see how in the same example for
song b if we draw a circle around the
song b we see that there are four words
for like whereas one would for dislike
if we go for the majority votes we can
say that paul will definitely like the
song that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of three grams it will be a one rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored high
runs and took less wickets while the
other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fair of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the surge pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 pm today okay i'll
remind you thanks no problem comment
below some interesting everyday examples
around you where machines are learning
and doing amazing jobs hi guys this is
apeksha from simply learn and we are
going to talk about the two types of
machine learning supervised and
unsupervised learning their types and
applications but before we talk about
them let's quickly understand what is
machine learning these days applications
use artificial intelligence and machine
learning to optimize speech recognition
i usually ask siri things i want to know
like hey siri how far is the nearest
subway so whenever we ask something to
siri a powerful speech recognition kicks
off and converts the audio into its
corresponding textual form which is then
sent to the apple servers for further
processing then neural language
processing algorithms are run to
understand the user's intent and then
finally siri tells you the answer well
this is what machine learning is all
about making the machines learn and act
like humans by feeding them with data
and information without being explicitly
programmed
as we saw in the previous example when
the data comes in machines immediately
starts analyzing the data and eventually
gets trained on it and learns it now
when a new data point comes in machine
accurately makes prediction and
decisions based on the past data now
that you know what is machine learning
let's talk about supervised and
unsupervised learning supervised
learning as the name suggests works
under supervision that is it's learning
in which machine is trained with data
which is well labeled and then predicts
with the help of the label data set but
what is a labeled data set data for
which you already know the target answer
is called a label data like i show you
an image and tell you that it's a dog
then it's a label data while if i show
you an image without telling you what
exactly it is then it's an unlabeled
data now let's say we have images which
are labeled as spoon or knife we then
feed it to the machine which analyzes
and learns the association of these
images with its labels based on its
features such as shape size sharpness
etc now when a new image is fed to the
machine without any label with the help
of the past data the machine is able to
predict accurately and tell that it's a
spoon hence in supervised machine
learning the algorithm teaches the model
to learn from the labeled example that
we provide so supervised learning can be
further divided into classification and
regression it is a classification
problem when the output variable is
categoric such as red or blue disease or
no disease male or female whereas it's a
regression problem when the output
variable is a real or continuous value
for example salary based on work
experience weight based on height so it
creates a predictive model showing
trends and data so now if i say will i
get a salary raise or not that's
classification but if i say how much
salary raise will i get that is
regression now let's understand
classification with the help of an
example in order to predict whether an
email is a spam or not first we need to
teach our machine what a spam mail looks
like this is done based on a lot of spam
filters like firstly reviewing the
content of the email then review the
email header and search if it contains
any falsified information this is done
based on some keywords like free
lottery
price claim etc then general blacklist
filters to stop emails that come from
already blacklisted known spammers and
etc so all these filters scores the
email which is known as spam score the
lower the total spam score of the email
it is more likely that the email will
land in subscribers in boxes so based on
the content
labels and spam score of the new
incoming mail the algorithm decides
whether it should land in inbox or the
spam folder
now let's quickly understand regression
so let's say we have two variables that
is temperature and humidity where
temperature is the independent variable
and humidity is the dependent variable
such that as the temperature increases
humidity decreases hence they are
correlated when we feed this data to a
regression model it will understand the
relationship between these two variables
and how one variable depends on the
other after the machine is trained it
can easily predict the humidity based on
the given temperature well that was
about regression now let's see some real
life applications where supervised
learning is used so supervised learning
is used in risk assessment to assess
risk in financial services or an
insurance domain to minimize the risk
portfolio of the companies image
classification facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photos so image classification is
one of the key use cases of
demonstrating supervised machine
learning algorithms obviously a lot more
goes into all these like convolutional
neural networks etc fraud detection
whether the transactions made by the
user are authentic or not and visual
recognition the ability of a machine
learning model to identify objects
places people and actions and images now
let's quickly talk about unsupervised
learning in unsupervised learning there
is no supervision that is no training
will be given to the machine allowing it
to act on the data which is not labeled
hence machine tries to identify patterns
and gives the response let's take a
similar example as before but this time
we do not tell the machine whether it's
a spoon or a knife the machine
identifies patterns from the given set
and groups them based on their patterns
similarities etc again unsupervised
learning can be further grouped into
clustering and association clustering is
basically where the machine forms groups
based on the behavior of the data
secondly association it is a rule-based
machine learning to discover interesting
relation between variables in large data
sets for example which customer made
similar product purchases is clustering
whereas association is which products
were purchased together now let's
understand clustering with the help of
an example to reduce their churn rate a
telecom company studies the behavior of
the customers based on average call
duration and internet usage and observes
that while some customers call duration
is quite high others have heavy internet
usage the customers are grouped based on
their observed behavior and a strategy
is adopted to minimize churn rate and
maximize profit by suitable promotions
and campaigns
as you can see in the chart on the right
hand side customers in group a uses more
data and also have high quality group b
customers are heavy internet users while
group c customers have high call
duration so group b will be given more
data benefit plans while group c will be
given cheaper call rates to buy their
loyalty so this was the example of
clustering now let's understand
association with another example let's
say customer one goes to a supermarket
and buys these products say bread milk
fruits wheat then customer two goes and
buys bread milk rice and butter
now when customer 3 goes and buys bread
it is highly likely that he will also
buy milk hence relationship is
established based on customer behavior
and recommendations are made now let's
look at some real life applications of
unsupervised learning market basket
analysis is a machine learning model
based on the algorithm that if you buy a
certain group of items you are less more
likely to buy another group of items
semantic clustering semantically similar
words share similar contexts people post
their queries on websites in their own
ways semantic clustering groups all
responses in a cluster with same meaning
to ensure that the customer finds the
information they want quickly and easily
it plays an important role in
information retrieval good browsing
experience and comprehension
delivery store optimization machine
learning models are used to predict the
demand and keep up with the supply also
to open stores where demand is more and
optimizing rules for more efficient
deliveries according to past data and
behavior we can also use unsupervised
machine learning models to identify
accident prone areas based on the
intensity of those accidents and the
area in order to introduce safety
measures by now i hope you've understood
supervised and unsupervised learning for
a quick recap let's see a few
differences between the two the most
fundamental difference is that
supervised learning uses known and
labeled data and unsupervised learning
uses unlabeled data as their input
secondly supervised learning follows a
feedback mechanism while unsupervised
learning does not also the most commonly
used algorithms in supervised learning
are decision tree logistic regression
support vector machine etc and at
unsupervised learning their k-means
clustering hierarchical clustering a
priori algorithm and many more welcome
to linear regression my name is richard
kirchner i'm with simply learn let's
look at an example of a common use for
linear regression profit estimation of a
company if i was going to invest in a
company i would like to know how much
money i could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our r d which is
your research and development we have
our marketing
we might have the location we might have
what kind of administration is going
through based on all this different
information we would like to calculate
the profit now in actuality there's
usually about 23 to 27 different markers
that they look at if they're a heavy
duty investor we're only going to take a
look at one basic one we're going to
come in and for simplicity let's
consider a single variable r and d and
find out which companies to invest in
based on that so we take r and d and
we're plotting the profit based on the r
d expenditure how much money they put
into the research and development and
then we look at the profit that goes
with that we can predict a line to
estimate the profit so we draw a line
right through the data when you look at
that you can see how much they invest in
the rnd is a good marker as to how much
profit they're going to have we can also
note that companies spending more on r d
make good profit so let's invest in the
ones that spend a higher rate in their r
d what's in it for you first we'll have
an introduction to machine learning
followed by machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in
let's start with our introduction to
machine learning along with some machine
learning algorithms and where that fits
in with linear regression let's look at
another example of machine learning
based on the amount of rainfall how much
would be the crop yield so here we have
our crops we have our rainfall and we
want to know how much we're going to get
from our crops this year so we're going
to introduce two variables independent
and dependent the independent variable
is a variable whose value does not
change by the effect of other variables
and is used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categoricals limited to
very specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months
score predictions cricket fever to
predict the number of runs a player
would score in the coming matches based
on the previous performance i'm sure you
can figure out other applications you
could use linear regression for so let's
jump in and let's understand linear
regression and dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is
m in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y2
minus y1 and x2 minus x1 and finally we
have c which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on we can
guess how good our crops are going to be
and we've created a nice line right
through the middle to give us a nice
mathematical formula let's take a look
and see what the math looks like behind
this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e
that's opened up that just means
summation that's all that is so when you
see the sigma character it just means
we're adding everything in that row and
for computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we've broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we're going to
explain exactly what that is in just a
minute and where that information comes
from is called the square means error
but we'll go into that in detail in a
few minutes all you need to do is look
at the formula and see how we've gone
about computing it line by line instead
of trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see y what we actual values
were and you can see why predict it you
can easily see where we take y minus y
predicted and we get an answer what is
the difference between those two and if
we square that y minus y prediction
squared we can then sum those squared
values that's where we get the 0.64 plus
the 0.36 plus 1 all the way down until
we have a summation equals 2.4 so the
sum of squared errors for this
regression line is 2.4 we check this
error for each line and conclude the
best fit line having the least e square
value in a nice graphical representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line now we
only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as in p and then i want you to
skip one line and look at import pandas
as pd these are very common tools that
you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
we usually like to use the pandas when
we can and i'll show you what that looks
like the other three lines are for us to
get a visual of this data and take a
look at it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed matte plot
library inline that is only because i'm
doing an inline ide my interface in the
anaconda jupiter notebook requires i put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of 136
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
sns which is pandas as you can see we
imported the map plot library dot pi
plot as plt which then the seaborn uses
and we imported the seaborn as sns and
then that final line of code helps us
show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the
matplot library in line with the amber
sign at the beginning so here we come
down to the single line of code seaborn
is great because it actually recognizes
the panda data frame so i can just take
the companies dot core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this we get this
beautiful plot and let's just take a
look at what this plot means if you look
at this plot on mine the colors are
probably a little bit more purplish and
blue than the original one we have the
columns and the rows we have r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as r d spending and
the same thing with administration costs
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark um diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital l label capital e encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across
we have column 0 which is r and d
spending column 1 which is
administration
column 2 which is marketing spending and
column 3 is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
is just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transferred all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our labeling
coding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models you usually see that a
capital x and you see the train and the
test and the lowercase y what this is is
x is our data going in that's our rnd
span our administration our marketing
and then y which we're training is the
answer that's the profit because we want
to know the profit of an unknown entity
so that's what we're going to shoot for
in this tutorial the next part train
test split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals point two
that basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting cause it's
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model now that we
got to the linear regression model we
get that next piece of the puzzle let's
go ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn dot linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
setting it up with the different lines
and then we also looked all the way down
to multiple linear regression where
we're adding all those formulas together
all of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when i run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from you can see
the formula down here where y equals m1
times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and
so on plus c the coefficient so these
variables fit right into this formula y
equals slope one times column one
variable plus slope two times column two
variable all the way to the m into the n
and x to the n plus c the coefficient or
in this case you have minus eight point
eight nine to the power of two etc etc
times the first column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look what that looks like
in code and so we're going to use this
from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model because remember it does
have a random generation involved this
proves the model is a good model which
means success yay we successfully
trained our model with certain
predictors and estimated the profit of
the companies using linear regression
what is logistic regression let's say we
have to build a predictive model or a
machine learning model to predict
whether the passengers of the titanic
ship have survived or not the shipwreck
so how do we do that so we use logistic
regression to build a model for this how
do we use logistic regression so we have
the information about the passengers
their id whether they have survived or
not their class and name and so on and
so forth and we use this information
where we already know whether the person
has survived or not that is the labeled
information and we help the system to
train based on this information with
based on this labeled data this is known
as label data and during the process of
building the model we probably will
remove some of the non-essential
parameters or attributes here we only
take those attributes which are really
required to make these predictions and
once we train the model we run new data
through it whereby the model will
predict whether the passenger has
survived or not all right what is
logistic regression as i mentioned
earlier positive regression is an
algorithm
for performing binary classification so
let's take an example and see how this
works let's say your car has not been
serviced for quite a few years and now
you want to find out if it is going to
break down in the future so this is like
a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot the information along the x and
y axis x is the number of years since
the last service was performed and why
is the probability of your car breaking
down and let's say this information was
this data rather was collected from
several car users it's not just your car
but several car users so that is our
labeled data so the data has been
collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are point one
probability similarly three years is
maybe point three and so on but as the
number of years increases let's say if
it was six or seven years there is
almost a certainty that your car is
going to break down that is what this
graph shows so this is an example of a
application of the classification
algorithm and we will see in little
details how exactly logistic regression
is applied here one more thing needs to
be added here is that the dependent
variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the hr
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employees information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the height so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get 5000 500
5600 it is not discrete like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or no these are
discrete values right so this way you
are trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on the scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out that is a
discrete problem right a yes or no kind
of a problem in this case we actually
cannot use linear regression even though
we may have labeled data so this is the
label data so based on the employee
rating these are the ratings and then
some people got the promotion and this
is the ratings for which people did not
get promotion that is a no and this is
the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer has
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors thus
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta0 plus beta1 x where beta0 is the
y-intercept and beta1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic is actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of px by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of p x you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not but it's
going to snow or not these are all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples classification of objects this
is a again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
uh
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier and we can
do some exploratory analysis and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we go we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagnose the cells other than
the diagonals should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the
number that has been fed is zero and the
number that has been detected is also
zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's uh just of how to
use this matrix how to use this
confusion matrix i know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has uh there are i think 37
plus five yeah 42 have been fed the
images 42 images are of digit three and
uh the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say zero to five or zero to
nine and um and then we will see how
well it is trained and whether it is
able to predict these numbers correctly
or not so let's get started so the first
part is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
1797
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at uh some of the
sample images that we have unloaded so
this one for example creates a figure
and then we go ahead and take a few
sample images to see how they look so
let me run this code and so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about five images sample images that we
are looking at zero one two three four
so this is how the image is this is how
the data is okay and uh based on this we
will actually train our logistic
regression model and then we will test
it and see how well it is able to
recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of the and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train
and y underscore train for the training
data set and what is x underscore train
these are these are the features right
which is like the independent variable
and why underscore train is the label
right so in this case what happens is we
have the input value which is or the
features value which is in x underscore
train and since this is the labeled data
for each of them each of the
observations we already have the label
information saying whether this digit is
a zero or a one or a two so that this is
what will be used for comparison to find
out whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way x underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set x underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of these so x
underscore train the shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is four one four so actually
there are 414 observations in test and
1383 observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set right this is our the
the predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is 4. so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can um also see this accuracy using what
is known as a confusion matrix so let us
go ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has
done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically import some of the
libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix
and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predictive value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's it's like more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test value so the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly 9 and actual value is 9 and
this is the image of 1 and again this
has been predicted correctly as like the
actual value okay so this was a quick
demo of logistic regression how to use
logistic regression to identify
images
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction let's start with
a simple question how to identify a
random vegetable from a shopping bag so
we have this group of vegetables in here
and we can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not
then it's going to be the purple fruit
to the left probably an eggplant if it's
true it's going to be one of the red
fruits is the diameter greater than 2 if
false is going to be a what looks to be
a red chili and if it's true it's going
to be a bell pepper from the capsicum
family so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 and the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so it's the final end at the
bottom the decision node has two or more
branches this is where we're breaking
the group up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the top
most decision note is known as the root
node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of in entropy after
splitting so the formula for entropy is
the sum that's what this symbol looks
like that looks like kind of like a e
funky e of k where i equals 1 to k k
would represent the number of animal the
different animals in there where value
or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gather and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case it's yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over total of eight
times log base two two over eight plus
one monkey over total of eight log base
two one over eight and plus two over
eight of the tigers log base 2 over 8.
and if we plug that into our computer
our calculator i obviously can't do logs
in my head we get an entropy equal to
0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we'll
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human it's probably
pretty easy to split it let's see if
you're right if you guessed the color
yellow you're correct let's say the
condition that gives us the maximum gain
is yellow so we will split the data
based on the color yellow if it's true
that group of animals goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right the
entropy after the splitting has to
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as the condition since
every branch now contains single label
type we can say that entropy in this
case has reached the least value and
here you see we have the giraffes the
tigers the monkey and the elephants all
separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the dataset with a
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to be pay their loan or
not for this bank and from that we want
to generate a problem statement to
predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing i need is
i need something to edit my python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
i'm using the anaconda jupiter notebook
now you can use any python ide you like
to run it in but i find the jupiter
notebook's really nice for doing things
on the fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we start let's talk a little bit
about what we're bringing in and then
we're going to do a couple things in
here we have to make a couple changes as
we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as np that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score
set up that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my c drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where i stored the data2.csv
file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i want to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sk learn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with 1. if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at 1 through 5
we can do the same thing for y which is
the answers and we're going to set that
just equal to the zero row so it's just
the zero row and then it's all rows
going in there so now we've divided this
into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves is five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person's going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook works as
a command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e in to print it i
could just as easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not we're going to be looking
at random forest one of the many
powerful tools in the machine learning
library before we dive into the topic
let's start by looking at a few of the
uses for random forest currently today
is used in remote sensing
for example they're used in the etm
devices if you're a space buff that's
the enhanced thermatic mapper they use
on satellites which see uh far outside
the human spectrum for looking at land
masses and they acquire images of the
earth's surface the accuracy is higher
and training time is less than many
other machine learning tools out there
also object detection multi-class object
detection is done using random forest
algorithms a good example is a traffic
where you're trying to sort out the
different cars buses and things and it
provides a better detection in
complicated environments it's very
complicated up there and then we have
another example connect and let's take a
little closer look at connect connect
they use a random forest as part of the
game console
and what it does is it tracks the body
movements and it recreates it in the
game and let's see what that looks like
we have a user who performs a step in
this case it looks like elvis presley
going there
that is then recorded so the connect
registers the movement
and then it marks the user based on
accuracy and it looks like we have
prints going on this one
from
elvis press leader prince that's great
so mark's user based on the accuracy if
we look at that a little closer we have
a training set to identify body parts
where are the hands where the feet
what's going on with the body
that then goes into a random forest
classifier that learns from it
once we've trained the classifier
and then identifies the body parts while
the person's dancing it's able to
represent that in a computer format and
then based on that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being elvis
presley or prince in your dancing so why
random forest it's always important to
understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing
which one fits better even though it's
missing that data let us dig deep into
the theory of exactly how it works
and let's look at what is a random
forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as the final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes those
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it into and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one
whatever comes in there it's going to
sort that data and it's going to say
okay if this data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction it's probably a
lemon so that brings us up to
information gain it is the measure of
decrease in the entropy after the data
set is split what that means in here is
that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so we look down here to the
leaf node we finally get to our set one
or our set two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes or
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit
and so let's create a problem statement
and the problem is we want to classify
the different types of fruits in the
bowl based on different features the
data set in the bowl is looking quite
messy and the entropy is high in this
case so if this bowl was our decision
maker it wouldn't know what choice to
make it has so many choices which one do
you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes
and how do we split the data we have to
frame the conditions to split the data
in such a way that the information gain
is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hearty
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into that
range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at there
very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree in our forest but what we really
want to know is how does a random forest
work as a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false are true and so on
and so on and tree three is the diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees you can see them
all in one image so this would be three
completely different trees categorizing
a fruit and let's take a fruit now let's
try this and this fruit if you look at
it we've blackened it out you can't see
the color on it so it's missing data
remember one of the things we talked
about earlier is that a random forest
works really good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white camera when they took
the picture and we're going to take a
look at this and it's going to have they
put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
3 we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value and say true and
you go to the right tree two classifies
it as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape a circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry uh
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.dataset
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sk learn module so
sklearn dot ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run
the imports and i'm going to paste the
code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at
the bigger picture and i'm going to go
print i'm just going to change this for
a moment and we're going to print all of
iris and see what that looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary and in a
python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length sepal
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head will print the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have zero one two three four in
python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five so now we've got
our iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you that where you
where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy dot random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25 we're going to
hold off to the side and use that to
test it later on so let's flip back on
over and see what the next step is so
now that we've labeled our database for
which is training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent and test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you can see that there's 150 lines
and that's roughly 75 and one and 25 for
us to test our model on afterward so
let's jump back to our code and see
where this goes in the next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are gonna be the features or the titles
of those columns and so when i run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or you're
running command line in the
terminal window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species
of zero because this is in the format of
a of an array of arrays so you have to
have the zero on the end and then
species is just that column factorize
goes in there looks at the fact that
there's only three of them so when i run
this you'll see that y generates an
array that's equal to in this case it's
the training set and it's zeros ones and
twos representing the three different
kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
zero is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is a
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window on a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
gonna automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false form start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model what's next if we're going to
create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length steeple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts zero zero zero one two one one
two two two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was uh what 27 you'll see right
down here that this generates a much
larger field on the probability and
let's take a look and see what that
looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability
it generates three numbers so we had
three leaf nodes at the end and if you
remember from all the theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one for setosa it predicts
a
zero for virginica and it predicts a
zero for versa color and so on and so on
and so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets point
five votes versus color gets point five
votes but let's just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here so now we've
looked at both how to do a basic predict
of the features and we've looked at the
predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run it we could have just
set a variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again clf dot predict test
features remember that returns the zeros
the ones and the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did predictions through
25 let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satosa setosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to because i'm on
the jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you add 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the
iris.target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this introducing naive
bayes classifier have you ever wondered
how your mail provider implements spam
filtering or how online news channels
perform news text classification or how
companies perform sentimental analysis
of their audience on social media all of
this and more is done through a machine
learning algorithm called naive bayes
classifier welcome to naive bayes
tutorial my name is richard kirschner
i'm with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you we'll start
with what is naive bayes a basic
overview of how it works we'll get into
naive bayes and machine learning where
it fits in with our other machine
learning tools why do we need naive
bayes and understanding naive bayes
classifier a much more in depth of how
the math works in the background finally
we'll get into the advantages of the
nave bayes classifier in the machine
learning setup and then we'll roll up
our sleeves and do my favorite part
we'll actually do some python coding and
do some text classification using the
naive bayes what is naive bayes let's
start with a basic introduction to the
bayes theorem named after thomas bayes
from the 1700s who first coined this in
the western literature naive bayes
classifier works on the principle of
conditional probability as given by the
bayes theorem before we move ahead let
us go through some of the simple
concepts in the probability that we will
be using let us consider the following
example of tossing two coins here we
have two quarters and if we look at all
the different possibilities of what they
can come up as we get that they could
come up as head heads they come up as
head tail tail head and tell tale when
doing the math on probability we usually
denote probability as a p a capital p so
the probability of getting two heads
equals one one-fourth you can see on our
data set we have two heads and this
occurs once out of the four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail occurs
three-quarters of the time you'll see in
three of the coin tosses we have tails
in them and out of four that's
three-fourths and then the probability
of the second coin being head given the
first coin is tail is one-half and the
probability of getting two heads given
the first coin is a head is one-half
we'll demonstrate that in just a minute
and show you how that math works now
when we're doing it with two coins it's
easy to see but when you have something
more complex you can see where these pro
these formulas really come in and work
so the bayes theorem gives us the
conditional probability of an event a
given another event b has occurred in
this case the first coin toss will be b
and the second coin toss a this can be
confusing because we've actually
reversed the order of them and go from b
to a instead of a to b you'll see this a
lot when you work in probabilities the
reason is we're looking for event a we
want to know what that is so we're going
to label that a since that's our focus
and then given another event b has
occurred in the bayes theorem as you can
see on the left the probability of a
occurring given b has occurred
equals the probability of b occurring
given a has occurred times a probability
of a over the probability of b this
simple formula can be moved around just
like any algebra formula and we could do
the probability of a after a given b
times probability of b equals the
probability of b given a times
probability of a you can easily move
that around and multiply it and divide
it out let us apply bayes theorem to our
example here we have our two quarters
and we'll notice that the first two
probabilities of getting two heads and
at least one tail we compute directly
off the data so you can easily see that
we have
one example h out of four one fourth and
we have three with tails in them giving
us three quarters or three four seventy
five percent
the second condition the second uh set
three and four we're gonna explore a
little bit more in detail now we stick
to a simple example with two coins
because you can easily understand the
math the probability of throwing a tail
doesn't matter what comes before it and
the same with the head so still going to
be 50 percent or one half but when that
come when that probability gets more
complicated let's say you have a d6 dice
or some other instance then this formula
really comes in handy but let's stick to
the simple example for now in this
sample space let a be the event that the
second coin is head and b be the event
that the first coin is tells again we
reversed it because we want to know what
the second event is going to be so we're
going to be focusing on a and we write
that out as a probability of a given b
and we know this from our formula that
that equals the probability of b given a
times the probability of a over the
probability of b and when we plug that
in we plug in the probability of the
first coin being tails given the second
coin is heads and the probability of the
second coin being heads given the first
coin being over the probability of the
first coin being tails when we plug that
data in and we have the probability of
the first coin being tails given the
second coin is heads times the
probability of the second coin being
heads over the probability of the first
coin being tails you can see it's a
simple formula to calculate we have one
half times one-half over one-half or
one-half equals point five or 4. so the
bayes theorem basically calculates the
conditional probability of the
occurrence of an event based on prior
knowledge of conditions that might be
related to the event we will explore
this in detail when we take up an
example of online shopping further in
this tutorial understanding naive bayes
and machine learning like with any of
our other machine learning tools it's
important to understand where the naive
bayes fits in the hierarchy so under the
machine learning we have supervised
learning and there is other things like
unsupervised learning there's also
reward system this falls under the
supervised learning and then under the
supervisor's learning there's
classification there's also regression
but we're going to be in the
classification side and then under
classification is your naive bayes let's
go ahead and glance into where is naive
bayes used let's look at some of the use
scenarios for it as a classifier we use
it in face recognition is this cindy or
is it not cindy or whoever or it might
be used to identify parts of the face
that they then feed into another part of
the face recognition program this is the
eye this is the nose this is the mouth
weather prediction is it going to be
rainy or sunny medical recognition news
prediction it's also used in medical
diagnosis we might diagnose somebody as
either as high risk or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease or other
ailments and news classification we look
at the google news and it says well is
this political or is this world news or
a lot of that's all done with a naive
bayes understanding naive bayes
classifier now we already went through a
basic understanding with the coins and
the two heads and two tails and head
tail tail heads etc we're going to do
just a quick review on that and remind
you that the naive bayes classifier is
based on the bayes theorem which gives a
conditional probability of event a given
event b and that's where the probability
of a given b equals the probability of b
given a times probability of a over
probability of b remember this is an
algebraic function so we can move these
different entities around we can
multiply by the probability of b so it
goes to the left hand side and then we
can divide by the probability of a given
b and just as easily come up with a new
formula for the probability of b to me
staring at these algebraic functions
kind of gives me a slight headache
it's a lot better to see if we can
actually understand how this data fits
together in a table and let's go ahead
and start applying it to some actual
data so you can see what that looks like
so we're going to start with the
shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in table form so you can see what the
math looks like and then we're going to
solve it in python and in here we want
to predict whether the person will
purchase a product are they going to buy
or don't buy very important if you're
running a business you want to know how
to maximize your profits or at least
maximize the purchase of the people
coming into your store and we're going
to look at a specific combination of
different variables in this case we're
going to look at the day the discount
and the free delivery and you can see
here under the day we want to know
whether it's on the weekday you know
somebody's working they come in after
work or maybe they don't work weekend
you can see the bright colors coming
down there celebrating not being in work
or holiday and did we offer a discount
that day yes or no did we offer free
delivery that day yes or no and from
this we want to know whether the person
is going to buy based on these traits so
we can maximize them and find out the
best system for getting somebody to come
in and purchase our goods and products
from our store now having a nice visual
is great but we do need to dig into the
data so let's go ahead and take a look
at the data set
we have a small sample data set of 30
rows we're showing you the first 15 of
those rows for this demo now the actual
data file you can request just type in
below under the comments on the youtube
video and we'll send you some more
information and send you that file as
you can see here the file is very simple
columns and rows we have the day the
discount the free delivery and did the
person purchase or not and then we have
under the day whether it was a weekday a
holiday was at the weekend this is a
pretty simple set of data and long
before computers people used to look at
this data and calculate this all by hand
so let's go ahead and walk through this
and see what that looks like when we put
that into tables also note in today's
world we're not usually looking at three
different variables in 30 rows nowadays
because we're able to collect data so
much we're usually looking at 27 30
variables across hundreds of rows the
first thing we want to do is we're going
to take this data and based on the data
set containing our three inputs day
discount and free delivery we're going
to go ahead and populate that to
frequency tables for each attribute so
we want to know if they had a discount
how many people
buy and did not buy did they have a
discount yes or no do we have a free
delivery yes or no on those dates how
many people made a purchase how many
people didn't and the same with the
three days of the week was it a weekday
a weekend a holiday and did they buy yes
or no as we dig in deeper to this table
for our bayes theorem let the event by
be a now remember we looked at the coins
i said we really want to know what the
outcome is did the person buy or not and
that's usually event a is what you're
looking for and the independent
variables discount free delivery and day
b so we'll call that probability of b
now let us calculate the likelihood
table for one of the variables let's
start with day which includes weekday
weekend and holiday and let us start by
summing all of our rows so we have the
weekday row and out of the weekdays
there's nine plus two so it's 11
weekdays there's eight weekend days and
11 holidays well it's a lot of holidays
and then we want to sum up the total
number of days so we're looking at a
total of 30 days let's start pulling
some information from our chart and see
where that takes us and when we fill in
the chart on the right you can see that
9 out of 24 purchases are made on the
weekday 7 out of 24 purchases on the
weekend and 8 out of 24 purchases on a
holiday and out of all the people who
come in 24 out of 30 purchase you can
also see how many people do not purchase
on the weekdays two out of six didn't
purchase and so on and so on we can also
look at the totals and you'll see on the
right we put together some of the
formulas the probability of making a
purchase on the weekend comes out 11 out
of 30. so out of the 30 people who came
into the store throughout the weekend
weekday and holiday 11 of those
purchases were made on the weekday and
then you can also see the probability of
them not making a purchase and this is
done for doesn't matter which day of the
week so we call that probability of no
buy would be 6 over 30 or 0.2 so there's
a 20 chance that they're not going to
make a purchase no matter what day of
the week it is and finally we look at
the probability of b if a in this case
we're going to look at the probability
of the weekday and not buying two of the
no buys were done out of the weekend out
of the six people who did not make
purchases so when we look at that
probability of the weekday without a
purchase is going to be .33 or 33
percent let's take a look at this at
different probabilities and based on
this likelihood table let's go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekday is 11 out of 30 or roughly 36 or
37 percent 0.367 the probability of not
making a purchase at all doesn't matter
what day of the week is roughly 0.2 or
20 percent and the probability of a
weekday no purchase is roughly two out
of six so two out of six of our no
purchases were made on the weekday and
then finally we take our p of a b
if you look we've kept the symbols up
there we got p of probability of b
probability of a probability of b if a
we should remember that the probability
of a if b is equal to the first one
times the probability of no buys over
the probability of the weekday so we
could calculate it both off the table we
created we can also calculate this by
the formula and we get the 0.367
which equals or 0.33 times 0.2 over
0.367 which equals 0.179
or roughly uh 17 to 18 percent and
that'd be the probability of no purchase
done on the weekday and this is
important because we can look at this
and say as the probability of buying on
the weekday is more than the probability
of not buying on the weekday we can
conclude that customers will most likely
buy the product on a weekday now we've
kept our charts simple and we're only
looking at one aspect so you should be
able to look at the table and come up
with the same information or the same
conclusion that should be kind of
intuitive at this point next we can take
the same setup we have the frequency
tables of all three independent
variables now we can construct the
likelihood tables for all three of the
variables we're working with we can take
our day like we did before we have
weekday weekend and holiday we filled in
this table and then we can come in and
also do that for the discount yes or no
did they buy yes or no and we fill in
that full table so now we have our
probabilities for
a discount and whether the discount
leads to a purchase or not and the
probability for free delivery does that
lead to a purchase or not and this is
where it starts getting really exciting
let us use these three likelihood tables
to calculate whether a customer will
purchase a product on a specific
combination of day discount and free
delivery or not purchase here let us
take a combination of these factors day
equals holiday discount equals yes free
delivery equals yes let's dig deeper
into the math and actually see what this
looks like and we're going to start with
looking for the probability of them not
purchasing on the following combinations
of days we're actually looking for the
probability of a equal no buy no
purchase and our probability of b we're
going to set equal to is it a holiday
did they get a discount yes and was it a
free delivery yes before we go further
let's look at the original equation the
probability of a if b equals the
probability of b given the condition a
and the probability times probability of
a over the probability of b occurring
now this is basic algebra so we can
multiply this information together so
when you see the probability of a given
b in this case the condition is b c and
d or the three different variables we're
looking at and when you see the
probability of b that would be the
conditions we're actually going to
multiply those three separate conditions
out probability of you'll see that in a
second in the formula times the full
probability of a over the full
probability of b so here we are back to
this and we're going to have let a equal
no purchase and we're looking for the
probability of b on the condition a
where a sets for three different things
remember that equals the probability of
a given the condition b
and in this case we just multiply those
three different variables together so we
have the probability of the discount
times the probability of free delivery
times the probability is a day equal a
holiday those are our three variables of
the probability of a if b and then that
is going to be multiplied by the
probability of them not making a
purchase and then we want to divide that
by the total probabilities and they're
multiplied together so we have the
probability of a discount the
probability of a free delivery and the
probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that one out of six were no purchase on
a discounted day two out of six were a
no purchase on a free delivery day and
three out of six were a no purchase on a
holiday those are our three
probabilities of a of b multiplied out
and then that has to be multiplied by
the probability of a no purchase and
remember the prop probability of a no
buy is across all the data so that's
where we get the 6 out of 30. we divide
that out by the probability of each
category over the total number so we get
the 20 out of 30 had a discount 23 out
of 30 had a yes for free delivery and 11
out of 30 were on a holiday we plug all
those numbers in we get
0.178 so in our probability math we have
a 0.178 if it's a no buy for a holiday a
discount and a free delivery let's turn
that around and see what that looks like
if we have a purchase i promise this is
the last page of math before we dig into
the python script so here we're
calculating the probability of the
purchase using the same math we did to
find out if they didn't buy now we want
to know if they did buy and again we're
going to go by the day equals a holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes and let a equal buy now right about
now you might be asking why are we doing
both calculations why why would we want
to know the no buys and buys for the
same data going in well we're going to
show you that in just a moment but we
have to have both of those pieces of
information so that we can figure it out
as a percentage as opposed to a
probability equation and we'll get to
that normalization here in just a moment
let's go ahead and walk through this
calculation and as you can see here the
probability of a on the condition of b b
being all three categories did we have a
discount with a purchase do we have a
free delivery with a purchase and did we
is a day equal to holiday and when we
plug this all into that formula and
multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount probability of
a free delivery probability of the day
being a holiday times the overall
probability of it being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out the full probability of
there being a discount the full
probability of being a free delivery and
the full probability of there being a
day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24 times 21 over 24
times 8 over 24 times the p of a 24 over
30 divided by the probability of the
discount the free delivery times the day
or 20 over 30 23 over 30 times 11 over
30 and that gives us our .98
so what are we going to do with these
two pieces of data we just generated
well let's go ahead and go over them we
have a probability of purchase equals
0.986 we have a probability of no
purchase equals 0.178
so finally we have a conditional
probabilities of purchase on this day
let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities and turn them into
percentages this is simply done by
taking the sum of probabilities which
equals 0.98686
plus 0.178 and that equals the 1.164
if we divide each probability by the sum
we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase is 84.71
percent and the likelihood of no
purchase is fifteen point two nine
percent given these three different
variables so it's if it's on a holiday
if it's a with a discount and has free
delivery then there's an eighty four
point seven one percent chance that the
customer is going to come in and make a
purchase hooray they purchased our stuff
we're making money if you're owning a
shop that's like is the bottom line is
you want to make some money so you keep
your shop open and have a living now i
promised you that we were gonna be
finishing up the math here with a few
pages so we're going to move on and
we're going to do two steps the first
step is i want you to understand
why you want to under why you want to
use the naive bayes what are the
advantages of naive bayes and then once
we understand those advantages we'll
just look at that briefly then we're
going to dive in and do some python
coding advantages of naive bayes
classifier so let's take a look at the
six advantages of the naive bayes
classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper the first one is
very simple and easy to implement
certainly you could walk through the
tables and do this by hand you got to be
a little careful because the notations
can get confusing you have all these
different probabilities and i certainly
mess those up as i put them on you know
is it on the top of the bottom got to
really pay close attention to that when
you put it into python it's really nice
because you don't have to worry about
any of that you let the python handle
that the python module but understanding
it you can put it on a table and you can
easily see how it works and it's a
simple algebraic function it needs less
training data so if you have smaller
amounts of data this is great powerful
tool for that handles both continuous
and discrete data it's highly scalable
with number of predictors and data
points so as you can see just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover not just three
different variables or sets you can now
expand this to even more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time predictions this is so
important this is why it's used in a lot
of our predictions on online shopping
carts uh referrals spam filters is
because there's no time delay as it has
to go through and figure out a neural
network or one of the other mini setups
where you're doing classification and
certainly there's a lot of other tools
out there in the machine learning that
can handle these but most of them are
not as fast as a naive bayes and then
finally it's not sensitive to irrelevant
features so it picks up on your
different probabilities and if you're
short on date on one probability you can
kind of it automatically adjust for that
those formulas are very automatic and so
you can still get a very solid
predictability even if you're missing
data or you have overlapping data for
two completely different areas we see
that a lot in doing census and studying
of people and habits where they might
have one study that covers one aspect
another one that overlaps and because
the two overlap they can then predict
the unknowns for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help predict features that aren't even
in there so now we're down to my
favorite part we're going to roll up our
sleeves and do some actual programming
we're going to do the use case text
classification now i would challenge you
to go back and send us a note on the
notes below underneath the video and
request the data for the shopping cart
so you can plug that into python code
and do that on your own time so you can
walk through it since we walk through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code doing text
classification very popular for doing
the naive bayes so we're going to use
our new tool to perform a text
classification of news headlines and
classify news into different topics for
a news website as you can see here we
have a nice image of the google news and
then related on the right subgroups i'm
not sure where they actually pulled the
actual data we're going to use from it's
one of the standard sets but certainly
this can be used on any of our news
headlines in classification so let's see
how it can be done using the naive bayes
classifier now we're at my favorite part
we're actually going to write some
python script roll up our sleeves and
we're going to start by doing our
imports these are very basic imports
including our news group and we'll take
a quick glance at the target names then
we're going to go ahead and start
training our data set and putting it
together we'll put together a nice graph
because it's always good to have a graph
to show what's going on and once we've
traded it and we've shown you a graph of
what's going on then we're going to
explore how to use it and see what that
looks like now i'm going to open up my
favorite editor or inline editor for
python you don't have to use this you
can use whatever your editor that you
like whatever interface ide you want
this just happens to be the anaconda
jupiter notebook and i'm going to paste
that first piece of code in here so we
can walk through it let's make it a
little bigger on the screen so you have
a nice view of what's going on uh and
we're using python 3 in this case 3.5 so
this would work in any of your 3x
if you have it set up correctly should
also work in a lot of the 2x you just
have to make sure all of the versions of
the modules match your python version
and in here you'll notice the first line
is your percentage matte plot library
inline now three of these lines of code
are all about plotting the graph
this one lets the notebook notes as an
inline setup that we want the graphs to
show up on this page without it in a
notebook like this which is an explorer
interface it won't show up now a lot of
ides don't require that a lot of them
like on if i'm working on one of my
other setups it just has a pop-up and
the graph pops up on there so you have a
that setup also but for this we want the
matplot library inline and then we're
going to import numpy as np that's
number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it that we use for
both of our sklearn module and we also
use it for any of the upper math
functions in python and it's very common
to see that as np numpy as np the next
two lines are all about our graphing
remember i said three of these were
about graphing well we need our
matplotlibrary.pi plot as plt and you'll
see that plt is a very common setup as
is the sns and just like the np and
we're going to import seaborn as sns and
we're going to do the sns.set
now seaborn sits on top of pie plot and
it just makes a really nice heat map
it's really good for heat maps and if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
just means we give it a color scale the
term comes from the brighter red it is
the hotter it is in some form of data
and you can set it to whatever you want
and we'll see that later on so those
you'll see that those three lines of
code here are just importing the graph
function so we can graph it and as a
data science test you always want to
graph your data and have some kind of
visual it's really hard just to shove
numbers in front of people and they look
at it and it doesn't mean anything and
then from the sklearn.datasets
we're going to import the fetch 20 news
groups very common one for analyzing
tokenizing words and setting them up and
exploring how the words work and how do
you categorize different things when
you're dealing with documents and then
we set our data equal to fetch 20 news
groups so our data variable will have
the data in it and we're going to go
ahead and just print the target names
data.target names and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see here we
have alt atheism comp graphics comp osms
windows miscellaneous and it goes all
the way down to talk politics dot
miscellaneous talk religion dot
miscellaneous these are the categories
they've already assigned to this news
group and it's called fetch 20 because
you'll see there's i believe there's 20
different topics in here or 20 different
categories as we scroll down now we've
gone through the 20 different categories
and we're going to go ahead and start
defining all the categories and set up
our data so we're actually getting here
going to go ahead and get it get the
data all set up and take a look at our
data and let's move this over to our
jupyter notebook and let's see what this
code does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here i could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing but we want to kind
of spell it out for you so you can see
the different categories it kind of
makes it more visual so you can see what
your data is looking like in the
background once we've created the
categories
we're going to open up a train set so
this training set of data is going to go
into fetch 20 news groups and it's a
subset in there called train and
categories equals categories so we're
pulling out those categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 news group subset
equals test and categories equals
categories let's go down one size so it
all fits on my screen there we go and
just so we can really see what's going
on let's see what happens when we print
out
one part of that data
so
it creates train and under train it
creates train dot data and we're just
going to look at data piece number five
and let's go ahead and run that and see
what that looks like and you can see
when i print train dot data number five
under train it prints out one of the
articles this is article number five you
can go through and read it on there and
we can also go in here and change this
to test which should look identical
because it's splitting the date up into
different groups train and test and
we'll see test number five is a
different article but it's another
article in here and maybe you're curious
and you want to see just how many
articles are in here we could do
length
of train dot data and if we run that
you'll see that the training data has 11
314 articles so we're not going to go
through all those articles that's a lot
of articles but we can look at one of
them just so you can see what kind of
information is coming out of it and what
we're looking at and we'll just look at
number five for today and here we have
it rewording the second amendment ids
vtt line 58 lines 58 in article
etc and you scroll all the way down and
see all the different parts to there now
we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you weight this if you look down here
we have different words and maybe the
word from well from is probably in all
the articles so it's not going to have a
lot of meaning as far as trying to
figure out whether this article fits one
of the categories or not so trying to
figure out which category fits in based
on these words is where the challenge
comes in now that we've viewed our data
we're going to dive in and do the actual
predictions this is the actual naive
bayes and we're going to throw another
model at you or another module at you
here in just a second we can't go into
too much detail but a deal specifically
working with words and text and what
they call tokenizing those words
so let's take this code and let's skip
on over to our jupyter notebook and walk
through it and here we are in our
jupyter notebook let's paste that in
there and i can run this code right off
the bat it's not actually going to
display anything yet but it has a lot
going on in here so the top we had the
print module from the earlier one i
didn't know why that was in there so
we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages and from the sklearn
features extraction dot text we're going
to import tf idf vectorizer i told you
we're going to throw a module at you we
can't go too much into the math behind
this or how it works you can look it up
the notation for the math is usually
tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times they're used in a
document how many times or how many
documents they're used in and it's a
well used formula that's been around for
a while it's a little confusing to put
this in here
but let's let her know that it just goes
in there and waits the different words
in the document for us that way we don't
have to wait and if you put a weight on
it if you remember i was talking about
that up here earlier if these are all
emails they probably all have the word
from in them from probably has a very
low weight it has very little value in
telling you what this document's about
same with words like in an article in
articles in cost of
maybe cost might or where words like
criminal weapons
destruction these might have a heavier
weight because you describe a little bit
more what the article is doing well how
do you figure out all those weights in
the different articles that's what this
module does that's what the tf idf
vectorizer is going to do for us and
then we're going to import our
sklearn.naive bayes and that's our
multinomial nb
multinomial naive bayes pretty easy to
understand that where that comes from
and then finally we have the skylearn
pipeline import make pipeline now the
make pipeline is just a cool piece of
code because we're going to take the
information we get from the tf idf
vectorizer and we're going to pump that
into the multinomial nb
so a pipeline is just a way of
organizing how things flow it's used
commonly you probably already guess what
it is if you've done any businesses they
talk about the sales pipeline
if you're on a work crew or project
manager you have your pipeline of
information that's going through or your
projects and what has to be done in what
order that's all this pipeline is
we're going to take the tfid vectorizer
and then we're going to push that into
the multinomial nb now we've designated
that as the variable model we have our
pipeline model and we're going to take
that model and this is just so elegant
this is done in just a couple lines of
code
model.fit and we're going to fit the
data and first the train data and then
the train target
now the train data has the different
articles in it you can see the one we
were just looking at and the train dot
target is what category they already
categorized that that particular article
as and what's happening here is the
train data is going into the tf id
vectorizer so when you have one of these
articles that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them i remember once running
a model on this and i literally had 2.4
million tokens go into this
so when you're doing like large document
bases you can have a huge number of
different words it then takes those
words gives them a weight and then based
on that weight based on the words and
the weights and then puts that into the
multinomial nb and once we go into our
naive bayes
we want to put the train target in there
so the trained data that's been mapped
to the tfid vectorizer is now going
through the multinomial in b and then
we're telling it well these are the
answers these are the answers to the
different documents so this document
that has all these words with these
different weights from the first part is
going to be whatever category it comes
out of maybe it's the
talk show or the article on religion
miscellaneous once we fit that model we
can then take labels and we're going to
set that equal to model.predict most of
the sklearn used the term dot predict to
let us know that we've now trained the
model and now we want to get some
answers and we're going to put our test
data in there because our test data is
the stuff we held off to the side we
didn't train it on there and we don't
know what's going to come up out of it
and we just want to find out how good
our labels are do they match what they
should be now i've already run this
through there's no actual output to it
to show this is just setting it all up
this is just training our model creating
the labels so we can see how good it is
and then we move on to the next step to
find out what happened to do this we're
going to go ahead and create a confusion
matrix and a heat map so
the confusion matrix which is confusing
just by its very name is basically going
to ask how confused is our answer did it
get it correct or did it miss some
things in there or have some missed
labels and then we're going to put that
on a heat map so we'll have some nice
colors to look at to see how that plots
out let's go ahead and take this code
and see how that take a walk through it
and see what that looks like
so back to our jupiter notebook i'm
going to put the code in there and let's
go ahead and run that code
take it just a moment and remember we
had the inline that way my graph shows
up on the inline here
and let's walk through the code and then
we'll look at this and see what that
means so make it a little bit bigger
there we go no reason not to use the
whole screen too big so we have here
from sk learn metrics import confusion
matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says i the prediction was
such the actual truth was either agreed
with it or is something different and
it's going to add up those numbers so we
can take a look and just see how well it
worked and we're going to set a variable
mat equal to confusion matrix we have
our test target our test data that was
not part of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate
otherwise it's not a valid model if we
can't properly test it with new data and
this is the labels we created from that
test data these are the ones that we
predict it's going to be so we go in and
we create our sn heat map the sns is our
seaborn which sits on top of the pi plot
so we create a sns dot heat map we take
our confusion matrix and it's going to
be
mat.t and do we have other
variables that go into the sns.heat map
we're not going to go into detail what
all the variables mean the annotation
equals true that's what tells it to put
the numbers here so you have the 166 the
one the zero zero zero one format d and
c bar equals false have to do with the
uh format if you take those out you'll
see that some things disappear and then
the x tick labels and the y tick labels
those are our target names and you can
see right here that's the alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous and then finally we have
our plt.x label remember the sns or the
seaborn sits on top of our matplot
library our plt and so we want to just
tell it x label equals a true is is true
the labels are true and then the y label
is prediction label so
we say a true this is what it actually
is and the prediction is what we
predicted and let's look at this graph
because that's probably a little
confusing the way i rattled through it
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and flip back to the slides
because they have a black background
they put in there that helps it shine a
little bit better so you can see the
graph a little bit easier so in reading
this graph what we want to look at is
how the color scheme has come out and
you'll see a line right down the middle
diagonally from upper left to bottom
right what that is is if you look at the
labels we have our predicted label on
the left and our true label on the right
those are the numbers where the
prediction and the true come together
and this is what we want to see is we
want to see those lit up that's what
that heat map does as you can see that
it did a good job of finding those data
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red spots on there where it missed
you know it's a little confused we talk
about talk religion miscellaneous versus
talk politics miscellaneous social
religion christian versus alt atheism it
mislabeled some of those and those are
very similar topics so you could
understand why it might mislabel them
but overall it did a pretty good job if
we're going to create these models we
want to go ahead and be able to use them
so let's see what that looks like to do
this let's go ahead and create a
definition a function to run and we're
going to call this function let me just
expand that just a notch here there we
go i like mine in big letters predict
categories we want to predict the
category we're going to send it s a
string
and then we're sending it train equals
train we have our training model and
then we had our pipeline model equals
model this way we don't have to resend
these variables each time
the definition knows that because i said
train equals train and i put the equal
for model and then we're going to set
the prediction equal to the
model.predict s so it's going to send
whatever
string we send to it it's going to push
that string through the pipeline the
model pipeline it's going to go through
and tokenize it and put it through the
tf idf convert that into numbers and
weights for all the different documents
and words and then i'll put that through
our naive bayes and from it we'll go
ahead and get our prediction we're going
to predict what value it is and so we're
going to return train dot target names
predict of zero and remember that the
train dot target names that's just
categories i could have just as easily
put categories in there dot predict of
zero so we're taking the prediction
which is a number and we're converting
it to an actual category we're
converting it from i don't know what the
actual numbers are but let's say zero
equals alt atheism
so we're going to convert that zero to
the word or one maybe it equals comp
graphics so we're going to convert
number one into comp graphics that's all
that is and then we got to go ahead and
and then we need to go ahead and run
this so i load that up and then once i
run that we can start doing some
predictions let me go ahead and type in
predict category
and let's just do predict category jesus
christ and it comes back and says it's
social religion christian that's pretty
good
now note i didn't put print on this one
the nice things about the jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name of
the variable out as returning the
variable train.target underscore names
it'll automatically print that for you
in your own id you might have to put in
print let's see where else we can take
this and maybe you're a space science
buff so how about sending
load to
international
space station
and if we run that
we get science space
or maybe you're a
automobile buff and let's do oh they're
going to tell me audi is better than bmw
but i'm going to do bmw is better
than an audi so maybe your car buff and
we run that and you'll see it says
recreational i'm assuming that's what
rec stands for autos so i did a pretty
good job labeling that one how about uh
if we have something like a caption
running through there president of india
and if we run that
it comes up and says talk politics
miscellaneous so when we take our
definition our function and we run all
these things through kudos we made it we
were able to correctly classify texts
into different groups based on which
category they belong to using the naive
bayes classifier now we did throw in the
pipeline the tf idf vectorizer we threw
in the graphs those are all things that
you don't necessarily have to know to
understand the naive bayes setup or
classifier but they're important to know
one of the main uses for the naive bayes
is with the tf idf tokenizer vectorizer
where tokenizes the word and as labels
and we use the pipeline because you need
to push all that data through and it
makes it really easy and fast you don't
have to know those to understand naive
bayes but they certainly help for
understanding the industry and data
science and we can see our categorizer
our naive bayes classifier we were able
to predict the category religion space
motorcycles autos politics and properly
classify all these different things we
pushed into our prediction and our
trained model before we dive into the
svm let's take a look at applications of
the support vector machine at least some
general ones that are commonly used with
it face detection text and hypertext
categorization classification of images
and bioinformatics these are only about
a few of those that are used with this
svm as we go through this lesson see if
you can figure out what other ones you
could apply it to and also which you
would want to use some other tools for
so in this example last week my son and
i visited a fruit shop dad is that an
apple or a strawberry so the question
comes up what fruit do they just pick up
from the fruit stand after a couple of
seconds you could figure out that it was
a strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry site at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
vector machine we've taken it and we've
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the fruit example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set of female
where you have their height and weight
174 65 174 88 and so on and we'll need a
sample data set of the male they have a
height 179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's
go ahead and put this on a graph so you
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we've drawn two lines through the data
in the middle that separates them in
from the women but to predict the gender
of a new data point we should split the
data in the best possible way and we say
the best possible way because this line
has a maximum space that separates the
two classes here you can see there's a
clear split between the two different
classes and in this one there's not so
much a clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyper plane is not
optimal if we select a hyper plane
having low margin then there is a high
chance of misclassification this
particular svm model the one we
discussed so far is also called referred
to as the ls vm so far so clear but a
question should be coming up we have our
sample data set but instead of looking
like this what if it looked like this
where we have two sets of data but one
of them occurs in the middle of another
set you can see here where we have the
blue and the yellow and then blue again
on the other side of our data line in
this data set we can't use a hyperplane
so when you see data like this it's
necessary to move away from a 1d view of
the data to a two-dimensional view of
the data and for the transformation we
use what's called a kernel function the
kernel function will take the 1d input
and transfer it to a two-dimensional
output as you can see in this picture
here the 1d when transferred to a
two-dimensional makes it very easy to
draw a line between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
both algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be over fitted to
a very specific instance or is going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive into
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo when we have the young child
going dad is that a group of crocodiles
or alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blops and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupyter notebook is i can
go up to view and i'm going to go ahead
and toggle the line numbers on to make
it a little bit easier to talk about and
we can even increase the size because
this is edited in this case i'm using
google chrome explorer and that's how it
opens up for the editor although anyone
any like i said any editor will work now
the first step is going to be our
imports and we're going to import four
different parts the first two i want you
to look at are line one and line two are
numpy as np and matplot library dot pi
plot as plt now these are very
standardized imports when you're doing
work the first one is the numbers python
we need that because part of the
platform we're using uses that for the
numpy array and i'll talk about that in
a minute so you can understand why we
want to use a numpy array versus the
standard python array and normally it's
pretty standard setup to use np for
numpy the map plot library is how we're
going to view our data so this has you
do need the np for the sk learn module
but the map plot library is purely for
our use for visualization and so you
really don't need that for the svm but
we're going to put it there so you have
a nice visual aid and we can show you
what it looks like that's really
important at the end when you finish
everything so you have a nice display
for everybody to look at and then
finally we're gonna i'm gonna jump one
ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import and make blobs and i told you
that we were going to make up data and
this is a tool that's in the sk learning
to make up data i personally don't want
to go to the zoo get in trouble for
jumping over the fence and probably get
eaten by the crocodiles or alligators as
i work on measuring their snouts and
width and length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your
setup and you're not sure about what
data you're going to put in there you
can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use and finally we have our
actual svm the sklearn import svm on
line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20.
so which each each group is going to
have 20 different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be zero one that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals svm dot
svc kernel equals linear and i set
sequel to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the width and
length of the snout and i did say i was
going to come up here and talk just a
little bit about our plot and you'll see
plt that's what we imported we're going
to do a scatter plot that means we're
just putting dots on there and then look
at this notation i have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from numpy if you did
that in a regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array it turns out that
our make blobs returns a numpy array and
this notation is great because what it
means is the first part is the colon
means we're going to do all the rows
that's all the data in our blob we
created under capital x and then the
second part has a comma zero we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with zero and
then one so we have column zero and
column one and you can look at this as
our xy plots the first one is the x plot
and the second one is the y plot so the
first one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and
10 and then the second one x of the one
is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going up the left
hand side s equals 30 is just the size
of the dot so we can see them it says
real tiny dots and then the c map equals
plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times will be a third line where we
regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i'm giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width of length 5 6
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf.predict new data so the clf and
the dot predict part is going to give us
an answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 one so predicted
the first one the three four is going to
be on the one side and the five six is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what
it's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section one two three and four is the
same code we had before and let's go
back up here and take a look at that
we're going to fit the values on our svm
and then we're going to plot scatter it
and then we're going to do a plot show
so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals
plt.gca now right now we're actually
spending a lot of time just graphing
that's all we're doing here okay so this
is how we display a nice graph with our
results in our data ax is very standard
used variable when you talk about plt
and it's just setting it to that axis
the last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1 30
and we've done the same thing for the y
space and then we're going to go in here
and we create a mesh grid and this is a
numpy command so we're back to our
numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small s x x equals n p line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grit so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the yy coordinates and the xx
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital y y and a
column of x's capital x x with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function and we're going to put
the x y in there so here we have all
this data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the xx dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y and the z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side is
going to generate three different values
the z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so that's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf dot support vectors we are
looking at column 0 and column 1 and
then again we have the s equals 100 so
we're going to make them larger and the
line width equals one face colors equals
none let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dashed lines and
they have the near data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth we're going to
cover the k nearest neighbors allowed to
refer to as k n n and k n is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller lengths of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because knn is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose the factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals 3 we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a seven we classify
as a triangle depending on what the
other data is around and you can see as
the k changes depending on where that
point is that drastically changes your
answer and we jump here we go how do we
choose the factor of k you'll find this
in all machine learning choosing these
factors that's the face you get he's
like oh my gosh did i choose the right k
did i set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias in
one direction or the other and in terms
of k n n the number of k if you choose
it too low the bias is based on it's
just two noises it's right next to a
couple things and it's going to pick
those things and you might get a skewed
answer and if your k is too big then
it's going to take forever to process so
you're going to run into processing
issues and resource issues so what we do
the most common use and there's other
options for choosing k is to use the
square root of n so it is a total number
of values you have you take the square
root of it in most cases you also if
it's an even number so if you're using
uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your k value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
k value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knn we can use k knn when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 hello kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of k n n positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple
spreadsheet format the data itself is
comma separated very common set of data
and it's also a very common way to get
the data and you can see here we have
columns a through i that's what one two
three four five six seven eight eight
columns with a particular attribute and
then the ninth column which is the
outcome is whether they have diabetes as
a data scientist the first thing you
should be looking at is insulin well you
know if someone has insulin they have
diabetes because that's why they're
taking it and that could cause issue in
some of the machine learning packages
but for a very basic setup this works
fine for doing the k n and the next
thing you notice is it didn't take very
much to open it up i can scroll down to
the bottom of the data there's 768
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see i have a number
of windows open up at the top the one
we're working in and since we're working
on the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell actually we want to go
ahead and first insert a cell below and
then i'm going to go back up to the top
cell and i'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if i run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice remind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our imports
we're going to import the pandas as pd
import numpy is np pandas is the pandas
data frame a numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have our imports so we've brought in our
pandas our numpy our two general python
tools and then you can see over here we
have our train test split by now you
should be familiar with splitting the
data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between -1 and 1. and then the
actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're gonna use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set 1 head data set 2 head
it only prints out the last one so i
usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame pandas
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose
any of those you'd be dead so not a
really good factor if they don't if they
have a zero in there because they didn't
have the data and we'll take a look at
that because we're going to start
replacing that information with a couple
of different things and let's see what
that looks like so first we create a
nice list as you can see we have the
values talked about glucose blood
pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan in numpy nan
is what that stands for is none it
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're going to play zeros with no
data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead
hopefully they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip nas we can
do that that is a pandas command there
the skip n a so we're going to figure
out the mean of that data set and then
we're going to take that data set column
and we're going to replace all the npn
with the means why did we do that we
could have actually just taken this step
and gone right down here and just
replaced zero and skip anything where
except you could actually there's a way
to skip zeros and then just replace all
the zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value and we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose
and if i run this this is going to print
all the different glucose levels going
down and we thankfully don't see
anything in here that looks like missing
data at least on the ones it shows you
can see it skipped a bunch in the middle
that's what it does if you have too many
lines in jupiter notebook it'll skip a
few and go on to the next in a data set
let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that
and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column zero to eight remember
column nine here it is right up here we
put it in here is outcome well that's
not part of the training data that's
part of the answer yes column nine but
it's listed as eight number eight so
zero to eight is nine columns so uh
eight is the value and when you see it
in here 0 this is actually 0 to 7 it
doesn't include the last one and then we
go down here to y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column 8 and you can do it this way with
this particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split
that's part of the sk learn right there
and we simply put in our x and our y
we're going to do random state equals 0.
you don't have to necessarily see it
that's a seed number i think the default
is one when you seed it i'd have to look
that up and then the test size test size
is 0.2 that simply means we're going to
take 20 of the data and put it aside so
that we can test it later that's all
that is and again we're going to run it
not very exciting so far we haven't had
any print out other than to look at the
data but that is a lot of this is
prepping this data once you prep it the
actual lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there with the actual
writing of our knn we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data if you remember
correctly we're fitting the data in a
standard scalar which means instead of
the data being from you know 5 to 303 in
one column and the next column is 1 to 6
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between -1 and 1. that's
what that standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're gonna go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means of
those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in no
no we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p r e d
predict it across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here and that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is at 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our f1 score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818
was pretty close to what we got and we
can pretty much round that off and just
say we have an accuracy of 80 percent
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model so what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to 2 there will be two clusters
if k is equal to 3 3 clusters and so on
and so forth that's what the k stands
for and of course there is a way of
finding out what is the best or optimum
value of k for a given data we will look
at that so that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from
maybe all over the country or all over
the world and this data has information
about the runs scored by the people
ordered by the player and the wickets
taken by the player and based on this
information we need to cluster this data
into two clusters batsman and bowlers so
this is an interesting example let's see
how we can perform this so we have the
data which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and boilers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is
so there are information there is
information on the y-axis about the run
scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and the center and so on
and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c from one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add b c to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how k means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between k
means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k-means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar
some objects are so the similarity is
measured using what is known as distance
measure and what are the various types
of distance measures there is euclidean
distance there is manhattan distance
then we have squared euclidean distance
measure and cosine distance measure
these are some of the distance measures
supported by k-means clustering let's
take a look at each of these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure
it's nothing but the square of the
euclidean distance as the name suggests
so instead of taking the square root we
leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares
and the lower this value is the better
the cluster is that means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers may be
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k
the within ss is measured and the value
of k which has the least amount of
within ss or wss that's taken as the
optimum value of k so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the y axis the within sum of squares
or wss and on the x axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have k is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the within s value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within ss value that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of k increases the decrease the rate of
decrease will not be so high it will
continue to decrease but probably the
rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an idea for example the optimum
value of k should be either 2 or 3 or at
the most 4 but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they've
been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is a
repetitive process iterative process and
if the centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
c1 and c2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster so i
hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of
k-means clustering so let's take a look
at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x one
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence so
let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step 2
we assign each data point to the closest
center so what we do we calculate the
distance of each x value from each c
value so the distance between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points grouped into k groups because we
we wanted to create k clusters right so
we have k groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assign them randomly so now in step 3 we
actually calculate the centroid of each
group which means the original point
which we thought was the centroid will
shift to the new position which is the
actual centroid for each of these groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step two which is what
we calculate again the distance of each
of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
to here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales so
how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of
the code in the slides and then we will
go into the python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual k-means clustering
process
so we will assign each of these points
to the centroids and then check whether
they are the optimal distance which is
the shortest distance and assign each of
the points data points to the centroids
and then go through this iterative
process till the whole process converges
and finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and uh the
centroids are like the location where
the store should be the optimum location
where the store should be so that's the
way we determine the best locations for
the store and that's how we can help
walmart find the best locations for
their stores in florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live alright so this is
the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how k
means clustering is used and even there
is a small implementation of k-means
clustering as well okay so let's get
started okay so this block is basically
importing the various libraries that are
required like matplotlib and numpy and
so on and so forth which would be used
as a part of the code then we are going
and creating blobs which are similar to
clusters now this is a very neat feature
which is available in scikit learn make
blobs is a nice feature which creates
clusters of data sets so that's a
wonderful functionality that is readily
available for us to create some test
data kind of thing okay so that's
exactly what we are doing here we are
using make blobs and we can specify how
many clusters we want so centers we are
mentioning here so it will go ahead and
so we just mentioned four so it will go
ahead and create some test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k means and then we create an
instance of k means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
4
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as with any other
machine learning functionality fit is
what we use the function or the method
rather fit is what we use to
train the model here there is no real
training kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so x has these values the data
that has been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in y underscore k means
when we call predict that is what it
does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from zero to
three so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from zero one two three so
that's what is seen here okay now so
this was a quick example of generating
some dummy data and then clustering that
okay and this can be applied if you have
proper data you can just load it up into
x for example here and then run the
cable so this is the central part of the
k-means clustering program example so
you basically
create an instance and you mention how
many clusters you want by specifying
this parameter and underscore clusters
and that is also the value of k and then
pass the data to get the values now the
next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering uh can be used in
maybe some real-life examples real-life
use cases all right so in this case here
what we are doing is basically
implementing the k means clustering
and there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points we
calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position with the center
position right so we calculate the new
centroid and then we check if the new
centroid is the coordinates or the
position is the same as the previous
centroid
the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is 0.0001 we can
consider that as convergence otherwise
what will happen is this will either
take forever or it will be never ending
so that's a small flaw here so that is
something additional checks may have to
be added here but again as mentioned
this is not the most sophisticated
implementation uh this is like a kind of
a rough implementation of the k means
clustering okay so if we execute this
code this is what we get as the output
so this is the definition of this
particular function and then we call
that find underscore clusters and we
pass our data x and the number of
clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of a implementation of k-means
clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory uh so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically
we have the image information is stored
in the form of pixels and if the image
is like for example 427 by 640 and it
has three colors so that's the overall
dimension of the of the initial image we
just reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower.jpg okay so let we load that and
this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about four for this 427
by 640 pixels all right so this is how
it looks now the issue here is these
values are large the numbers are a large
so we need to normalize them to between
zero and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between zero and 1.
this is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points
and plot it and check and see how this
looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini-batch k-mean so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been
lost
it pretty much looks like the original
image yes we can see that for example
here there is a little bit uh it appears
a little dullish compared to this one
right because we kind of took off some
of the finer details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again we
can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will
also bring this as you can see the
numbers are much big so we will much
bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a two
dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done uh using
k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering we talk about the principal
component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company b-packs isomax and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
id a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're rerunning them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
uh leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it
principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up so
what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points and so we look down at
from one angle we've drawn a line down
there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in so we want to do is we want to
find the best view in this case we're
just looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our ease we can consider that
we get two principal components namely
pc1 and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line
important properties important
properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense uh you're
not going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one principal
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values which is the
feature vector and if you remember the i
gene vector is like a translation for
moving the data
from x equals 1 to x equals 2 or
whatever altering it and the i gene
value is the final value that we
generate
we talk about standardization the main
aim of this step is to standardize the
range of the attributes so that each one
of them lie within similar boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
i gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so when we have like multiple
variables how do we calculate that new
variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has
hygiene vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables now for this
matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component
is a line that best accounts for the
shape of the point swarm it represents
the maximal variance direction in the
data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in three six
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python three
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries
the first thing i like to do whenever
i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on that plot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library online the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description um
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup uh what's important is
you start looking at what the different
attributes are what they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print
target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9 um so in other
words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that come most the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know we're looking at we're
just handed a bunch of stuff as a data
scientist going what the heck is this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
it's difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else
if you're showing this to the
shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
and we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it uh we've already looked at
our minimum maximum we've already looked
at what's in each quarter we've done a
full description of the data this is
part of describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and uh
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
of one these are two different
perceptions we're using
and then
you'll see right here c for color
cancer equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principal component second
principal component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple of things when i'm looking
at this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be b9
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here clearly by using these
two components we can easily separate
these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do uh look at the pca components
this is in our model we built we've
trained it we can run that and you can
see here's the actual components uh it's
the two components have each have their
own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores they're using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down i've already got it down here
we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's needed about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and uh
and set it up for us we want
and so we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression
bias and variance
what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and under fitting
what does that mean
and what is regularization and then
we'll do a quick hands-on demo to take a
look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
so we might have in this case just the
two dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1 000 kilometers
so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds the line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example let's
say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream
and we're looking at how warm it is
outside which would hopefully draw a lot
of people into the ice cream store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss
and we have a positive distance and a
negative distance and of course when we
square it it is neither it just becomes
a positive error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in a code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse
i know that's a mean squared error
and we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be
ninety
6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2
hence l1 is the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes it is we're going to
keep guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite to
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best and the mean square error
is one of the better fits to doing for
doing this and most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning
and with linear regression
so bias
bias occurs when an algorithm has
limited flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
uh
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
uh and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and
with bias if you oversimplify it so much
you're going to miss
your
local
uh if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data
and i want you to think about this
when we're talking about a bias
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants
suddenly a
truck has to have certain features
and it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it has
to be red if it's blue then it has to be
a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data
and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training
or on the test data
then your bias then you're biasing your
data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
in regression of any kind or any kind of
setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting
when we talk about overfitting it's a
scenario where the machine learning
model tries to learn from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point on the curve
you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because
if the wind blows a certain way
in the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind
so your car might alter how efficient it
is as it goes and so there's going to be
this variance on here and this says no
you can't have any variance with you
know the this is it's going to be
exactly this it can't be any you can't
be the same speed or the same car and
have a slightly different
efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
uh so you'll get like a really high
error on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data
and it's so important it's so important
that if you have if you have some kind
of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they use in
medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car
you may have 100 tests but because the
wind's blowing it's all over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
[Music]
uh the mod the most common is the
driving cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit
a linear curve that best fits the data
is neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include included
underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guess work out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
underfitting
so what that means uh in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our
in this case the lambda is going to be
the penalty for the errors we've thrown
in a greek character for you just to
confuse everybody and w is the slope of
the curve of the line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sklearn you could import
just a standard linear regression model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but you don't want to get
into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero uh considering the two
points on the line we'll go ahead and do
lambda equals one we'll set our w is
going to be 1.4
then the cost function equals 0 plus
1 times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so
really don't get caught up too much in
the math on this other than
understanding
that this is something that's very easy
for a computer to calculate and if you
ever see the loss plus the plus the
lambda times w the sum of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with the
0.0.62
so we now had a linear regression model
we now had a ridge regression model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model uh we're squaring the
value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot uh the ridge and this is
important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
uh ridge regularization is useful when
we have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the bottle does not encourage
conversions towards zero but is likely
to make them closer to zero and prevent
overfitting
the lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we have
four or five variables as we measure the
different leaf pieces uh you might be
doing the measurements on the cancer
project which has 36 different variables
um so as we get down to the iris with
four variables
lasso lar will probably work pretty good
where you might use the regularization
with more model with if you have
something significantly larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and
do a demo and lasso and ridge regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up our
jupiter notebook
we'll start with our imports pandas is
pd import numpy is np import matplot
library as plt
sklearn we're going to import our data
sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together we have our sklearn
model selection we're going to import
our train test split for splitting our
data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up
and then load our data set we're just
talking about that
you could just
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go ahead and pop that down
there and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston data we're going to look we put
it into our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns we want to see what's going on
with them
we have our target
we have the house price etc and so our x
equals boston
eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the boston
panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is
everything
except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then y is all the rows
but just the last column so y is our
house price
and the x is the
crimsian industry chas knox and all
these other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data uh
x train and our x uh test y train y test
equals the train test split which we
imported and we have our boston you
could have easily used the x and y on
here as opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 of the data and put it
in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this
i need an extra drink there
so we have our train and test and then
of course the print the train data shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct uh so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match and if
they're if the the data sets are not
quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird just
happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and we'll call this lreg lrag linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x train and y
train then we'll generate the prediction
on the test set
so here's our l reg y predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up
but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here
when we plot the coefficient scores on
here
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and
bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going and we're going
to import our ridge model
the red regression from the sk learn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals one and i
mentioned that earlier
when i work with the ridge model
you'll see alpha equals one if you set
alpha equal to zero that's a standard
linear regression model so you have
alpha equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four and a
standard integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that for our x
test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this all look
familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now
if i jump up and down between these two
you'll get a headache
[Laughter]
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the nox because that was
the biggest value it's a minus 9 here
and if we go back up here the knox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat i'm
seeing a huge change
in the biggest coefficient there
so if we're going to do that nice setup
we want to go ahead and just print it
and see what that looks
like here we go and we've
set up our plot subplots and again the
team put together some nice colors so it
makes it look good
we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our l regress coefficients color
equals color x spine bottom and so forth
uh so just put together a nice little
graph
and you're starting to see
one this when you compare this if you
put on the same graph as this one up
here this is up here minus 18.
this is at minus nine
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to uh knox
look where nox is it's all the way down
to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8 and really
here's our 22.73
let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
uh 16.69
and so we look at this uh if i was
running this and doing a working on a
project with this i would look at these
numbers i start with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78
6 9 is better than 7 8.
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved uh we
might know that uh the knocked value is
central and the other ones aren't quite
as good and so we might start looking at
just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have
a certain meaning to us and so forth and
so you can look at all those different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models our mean
square error on the test set
continues to come down on this
and that brings us to the end of this
live session on supervised and
unsupervised machine learning i hope you
liked it if you have any questions then
please feel free to put them in the
comments section thank you for watching
you